a friend of the program back here again
my colleague from the nfl media group
and in my mind a future hall of fame
wide receiver
my colleague from the nfl media group
steve
smith how are you steve smith senior
what's going on rich it's good to hear
from you it's been what
no when you say that in that inflection
it means like i'm not reaching out to
you steve is that what you're implying
right there or am i just being a little
sensitive
right now oh you're just being sensitive
i was just talking about the pandemic we
haven't been ever traveled oh
now i feel like garbage you know but if
you if you feel some type of way and
telling
yourself that's on you bro
all right it's good talking to you steve
oh man so let's uh let's hit the wayback
machine let's start our conversation in
the wayback machine what was it like for
you wednesday before your super bowl
it was the first one we ever covered for
nfl network what was it like what was
going through your temples
man it was the first one you guys
covered and
it ended up being the last one uh that i
was the first one i covered as
uh with the nfl network back in houston
after i retired so
uh it was amazing um a lot of feelings
uneasiness
you know we you're going you know
what you have experienced you know what
you've done to get here
but there there still is that 50 50.
50 you can lose 50 you can win and then
unexpected uh and i think that's what
gets more gets you more than anything
is you're not sure what's going to
happen i think more of anything will all
you know with all the
with everything going on uh you know you
you see uh
tyreke talking about you know keeping
herself distance himself from people
making sure
that um you know no cover 19 or any
false positives or you know contact
trading so i think it's a lot
i think this one is like winning the
lotto um except the only part is you
don't get to buy the ticket you
you just know you're not going to win if
if you
run into the risk of of contracting
other or getting a false positive before
the game
so i talked to willie about the match-up
uh of these two stellar
bucks linebackers and and david and
white
with travis kelsey coming at them so
i'm i i'd love to hit you on the other
matchup that seems to be
so problematic for the bucks and it
certainly was in the first quarter of
their
week 12 match up in the regular season
tyreek hill how
did the bucks do you think how do you
think todd bowles switches it up
or tightens it up uh against a guy who
went off three touchdowns and damn near
300 yards receiving in week 12
against him well he has to tighten it up
and switch it up uh but i think that
that's the chess match
is uh their defense their dealing with
vita they are coming back
um i think they do create a bigger issue
for the kansas city chiefs because
they don't have their left tackle right
and and and they have
mike rimmers and um not every player in
the league
is a great player sometimes they're just
guys who are there and mike remember uh
he was here
in carolina and then moved on in
minnesota and now he's out there
he wasn't necessarily a starter he's a
backup uh he
he can block but this is the last game
of the season this is a super bowl the
creme de la creme
all the chips are in or on the table
so you you would imagine they're going
to try to attack the weakest link and
the weakest link isn't necessarily
because he's not very good
it's because he's the new guy on the
block there's a reason why he's
he was not starting he was not the guy
so
uh unfortunately we may find that out
and uh uh
and jason pierre paul is he
you know he's no sloucher he's gonna
he's gonna let you know that he
he's present on the field these dbs are
gonna have to step
up because this offense for the kansas
city kansas city chiefs
is explosive and coach andy reid is
masterful when he has a couple of days
off when he has a week to prepare
he's going to take what we call jedi
mind trick window dressing he's going to
take his
tendencies utilize it against you
and dangle that care make you try to
bite for it and then
double move you so you got to be
prepared for that and then that means
you're not going to bite on a double
move so they're going to do some things
that make you second guess make you stop
your feet
and when you have speedsters like
mikhail harmon like
tariq when you stop your feet and those
guys are running 19
18 miles 21 plus miles per hour
and you stop your feet you're not gonna
catch up by the time you catch up
they're across the finish line which is
the end how would you have handled uh
back in the day
prior to the super bowl if there was a
scottie miller saying i'm faster than
steve smith how would you handle it i
mean i watch scotty
you know he's fast i i don't necessarily
know how fast he is
but i love i i love his confidence you
know
i tell my kids all the time it's hard to
belie it's hard for me to believe
in you if you don't believe in yourself
so he believes in himself
i think it'd be entertaining if he wins
great if he loses
great he's he's in the conversation and
that's the whole point
yeah i mean uh you know it's been a
minute again as you pointed out since
we've we've spoken here on this show if
you go higher register as you just did
to start your comment about stevie
uh scottie miller you don't really maybe
believe it you need to go ah
i'm way up here like you just started
your statement with scottie miller so
did that just happen i i no i just
the thing is i don't want to doubt the
man yes
but again i also see tyree kill i've
seen him more than i've seen scottie
miller yes
so it's it's almost you know
you know i love food and i use food
analogies it's a peanut butter jelly
sandwich or grilled cheese
i mean it really depends on what's you
know is this
tomato bisque then i'm going with the
grilled cheese
so which one is which in is your
is tyric the pbj or which one is it
i'm i'm not going against hurry hill and
if scotty miller proves me wrong
hey i've been wrong many times before it
seems steve smith
steve's with senior it seems that this
is the uh
the mother of all you know can't bet
against this guy
super bowl you you know you consider
well hey chiefs x y and z but how are
you going to be getting
tom brady or uh bucks xyz but how are
you gonna bet against
mahomes or kelsey or
obviously hill it's just and then evans
is doing has done something with seven
thousand yard seasons to start his
career no
other human has ever done and godwin and
gronk and this is it i mean how
how how do you is this the most talented
super bowl
you've seen i believe what do you think
i was thinking i was thinking about this
this reminds me of when i was growing up
and watching football
the nfc when it was the
was it the green bay packers with with
with sterling sharp or was it michael
irvin
you know with the cowboys or was it
jerry weiss with the san francisco 49ers
you have just such dominant teams
that whoever you pick you can't go wrong
because they've shown us
that they have the the capability of
playing excellent football
and so for me offensively so
if you're offensive guy or you're a
county who
loves numbers this is where you sit on
the couch
you go ahead and tell your workout
person your nutritionist
i'm off this weekend sunday is my
multiple cheat day on steroids
and i am gonna eat drink
and watch football because it's going to
be high flying
you know and you got to follow it up
with some great beverages because you're
just going to be eating and
and sto says bring your popcorn i mean
you got to have the appetizers with your
wings
you got to have your main course which
is pizza and then you got to have
your dessert which is cake pie whatever
it is a ho ho a ding dong
but you got to just pick out because
it's gonna be epic
football and we're at the house you know
everybody has the covet 20
15 10 whatever it is and this is a great
excuse to do it
so you go hostess for your desserts is
that where you're going the hostess
the household the homeowners the ding
dongs
you know honestly i'm uh it depends on
the day
but i will sneak in um a zinger or
the i like the chocolate twinkies oh
wow okay by the way this is
entire segment is making me hungry i
mean yeah del tufo can't handle it right
steve what are you doing
he's out of his mind right now okay um
so uh what do you make of desean watson
situation steve smith what did you do
what advice would you give him right now
yeah what do you think
um where'd he go with him listen it it's
crazy
is bananas um i'll be honest
um i'm not a huge fan of
of kali i don't think he listen when
you're 65 years old
and the first time head coach
i look at it why and there's a reason i
don't know the answer
but i know when it's you when you're 65
years old and you're just getting the
opportunity to be a head coach
there might be reasons why and then he
was also
the past coordinator for the baltimore
ravens how is that working out for the
baltimore ravens in the playoffs
they're dead last now some people say
i'm hating or i'm throwing shade
it's possibly true because i have a
history of david culley
because he was the coach at the pro bowl
who told me to go on over with the wire
gold which is specialist so i think he
doesn't necessarily know how to
hide talent when you go back into his
catalog of wide receivers of developing
he's had some good wide receivers
veterans on the team
but you never really see him develop any
wide receivers
under his tenure kansas city chiefs he
was with them
when did they win the super bowl after
he was gone right
i i just you know my job is to look at
coaches and players and sometimes i get
a bad
you know a bad rap as i'm i'm uber
critical but
i just don't see a guy who has never
really
had responsibilities to this depth being
successful
when your team is in shambles because
your
quarterback doesn't want to be there and
you go on the podcast you're
down talking some of your wide receivers
that you coached
and now you're talking about other
people when your
quarterback your franchise the face of
your of your team
doesn't want to be there i think you
probably should be
investing your time and equity in things
that are productive
and i just don't i don't i think he's
going to be look i think it's a wally
pill
all these great coordinators out here i
think in two three years they found out
that was a mistake he'd be moved on
so two things real quick um he's got a
no trade clause
and it the texans say they have no
intention of of
trading him like so what move do you
make if you're if you're him
well you know there's a lot of things
that people say in front of camera but
a lot of things go on behind closed
doors and i believe deshaun if he really
wants to get out there
out of there i think he can um
i also believe that the way they've
operated the way they've done things
i think it has rubbed him the wrong way
and i'm i'm not really sure that
this relationship will get better
because i believe and what i've heard is
so he was deshawn was supposed to be
part of some of the dialogue and
conversations and input
through the steps which the houston
texans
said they would allow him to be part of
the process
he has not been part of the process in
those steps
and so he believes from my
interpretation of things that
if they told me this and then they did
that what else are they going to do in
my future
that is going to not align with what
their words are saying
you got to understand he gets no do-over
and sometimes
money just because you pay someone
doesn't mean they're gonna do everything
you want them to do not
not everybody um you can buy and i think
he's
at the position he knows his value and i
believe he
feels that maybe i would just prefer
to go somewhere else and and start over
because i can't trust them
and then david cully steve
are you talking about a a 20-year-old
grudge
with him where you made the pro bowl as
a
rookie no i'm not i'm just giving i'm
just giving context
of why i'm just giving context
of it's not a grudge it's one of the
things is
when i look at if rich you've been doing
this for a long time
if you weren't very good in it you
wouldn't be doing it this long
so if all of a sudden you're an analyst
and you've never host it and you go out
there and host
and then you stumble over yourself that
would kind of say you're probably not a
good host
so what happened in 2001 you made it as
a kick returner right as a rookie
you're a rookie right and and yes and
you
tell the story go ahead so here's what
happened so i was a rookie
um i think toward this year that the
rams lost to
tom brady new england patriots yes sir
they didn't come to this they didn't
come to the pro bowl that's when the pro
bowl was in hawaii
um and after the super bowl he didn't
come
so john harbaugh said hey they're
they're down the wire receiver go over
there
how it was you know you know how to
catch punch the punter tyler solomon
was not always punctual all the time
so he said go over there they need a
body go run i know jermaine
lewis will be running some plays for the
afc so go ahead
go over there cuz he says hey hey uh
we're
we're about to meet so go ahead and go
with uh backwards and special teams i
said well the trust teams coach
control ball told me to come over here
well these are wide receivers that's
what he said
and i walked back over there and he told
me he goes oh
and so after that it just kind of tells
me so
the reason i say that is to this day
coach kelly will say
like you said you still holding that
grudge it's not holding a grudge just
the fact
i was a pro bowler i was also you were
down the wide receiver
and the fact of the matter is you
scooted me along because you didn't
believe i was a real wide receiver so
that tells me your
eye for athleticism and talent
um is as good as ray charles and
stevie's wonderful eyes
[Laughter]
you know i could do this all day and
we would like you to but he is uh
he's going to he has years to go i've
been told
uh but i love you steve okay um
uh cut to it your pod you're potting now
huh
i love it yeah can i can i come on your
podca i owe you so much you come on my
you came my pod you've come on this show
will you
have me on let's do this seriously
absolutely i
i would love to have you on you i'll
have
my people contact you
right hey listen you know where to reach
the only one flexing you know i'm not on
peacock but hey i can you know i can
have
i have my dude text your dude and then
we could play the whole
let me check my schedule don't you could
do that for sure and
but you know i i could at least attest
to the fact the reason why it's taking
this long for me to get your podcast
doesn't mean you can't podcast
you know what i'm saying oh no i'm not
i'm not your opportunity now
you're not the david podcasting is what
i'm saying you got the colleague
i joke around but uh i'm it's at the end
of it we
i love doing it because i love talking
about
talking to guys and finding out and and
girls finding out
who they are we're interviewing i
believe next week we're interviewing
jennifer king uh the new full-time head
coach full-time coach for the washington
washington football team and so uh
excited about that so we have
all kind of folk on there so we'd love
to have you on there
um to just hear who you are and you know
what makes you kick
other than the mic and and and also i'd
love it steve
i really would i really really would and
then i'm not just saying that
for real please reach out to me you know
you know i'll be around
for sure steve thanks for the call i
appreciate it i'll see you
i'll see you am i seeing you in tampa or
are you just you're you're no no no
i'm i'm here in charlotte um okay you
know it's
it's you know how it is man it's it's
craziness and it is to be honest
i don't want to q-tip up my nose every
five minutes i prefer now
you know what uh i totally can relate um
and that way that way you can just be
part of the program
and uh and then go have your ho hos and
ding dongs and pizzas and whatever you
got for
super sunday and then we'll have you on
right after that how does that sound
take that works you take care you be one
all right there you go
steve smith everybody check out cut to
it new pod where all pods are available
and steve will be part of
nine and a half hours eight and a half
hours i'm
i'm extending it because uh we need we
need to have more time for